pour l'heure on fait en temps comme si
de rien n'était à quelques semaines de
la rentrée les enfants scolarisés sont
en pleine révision après seulement 1 en
martinique
les progrès sont étonnants on se
rappelle du 100 m
je mets la vie sont simples il a demandé
papa maman et les roues son papa a dit
je t'aime maman elle a un jeu vient d'où
cette histoire d'amour c'est difficile
d'écrire le français tous sont inscrits
pour la prochaine année scolaire
mais la plus grande incertitude plane
sur leur avenir le couple et leurs sept
enfants ont reçu un avis d'expulsion ils
doivent quitter la martinique le 16 août
un coup dur pour ces deux mini key
réfugier ici chez leur grand mère
martiniquaise depuis l'ouragan maria ses
maisons d'hôtes et aboie et billy matin
à buizingen le glas d'un nouveau dtn à
l'esj paris au début du mois la famille
effectué un recours gracieux pour tenter
de faire annuler l'expulsion karabatic a
souhaité rappeler type dcg la consommer
de ceux qui travaillent parce que tu
sais jamais où madame proposé mais
quelques minutes plus tard
mais quand cela c'est n'aurait pas
forcément la nouvelle tombe comme un
couperet pour faire de votre bonne
décision et des décisions c'est non on
va senti qu'on maîtrise pas ce que
c'était mais là et puis la nouveau-née
bourse à vos côtés nous ingérons aurait
immédiatement parce que nous prenions
maison des remises dans cette démarche
la famille durand a reçu l'appui du
maire de la commune
il faut dire que le prêcheur entretient
des liens historiques avec ses voisins
dominicaine
je crois qu'il faut surtout pas oublier
que dans l'histoire à plusieurs reprises
de notre histoire mais les dominicains
ont été solidaires c'est mon moment je
veux dire de l' esclavage
c'était le cas aussi domaine de 1909
avec l'éruption de la montagne pelée
on n'en parle pas souvent mais de
nombreuses martiniquaise de nombreux
martiniquais ont trouvé également refusé
à la dominique
sans parler de la période de la
dissidence recours hiérarchique recours
contentieux
d'autres procédures sont encore
possibles en attendant et en l'état
actuel des choses la famille durand
droit quitter la martinique ce jeudi